- All right, let's finish
up with something sure
to make you smile, "This
is what I'm liking".
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
Early this year, 11 year
old Brody, came out as gay
and sadly, some people
were just awful about it.
A few of his friends were mean
or they just flat out
stopped talking to him.
You know, kids.
Well, it's no wonder when his
12th birthday rolled around,
he had no interest in having a party,
telling his mom, "I don't
have anyone to invite."
Like a good mom, she came up with a plan.
She put together a surprise
barbecue at a local park
and posted an invite for her
friends on social media to see.
Nearly a hundred friends and
total strangers showed up
to help celebrate Brody.
(audience cheering)
Let's take a look.
(indistinct)
- [Woman] People just wanted to tell you
how much they love you.
- This is the best birthday ever!
(people cheering)
(audience cheering)
- All right, we have Brody and his mom
on the line right now.
(audience cheering)
Hi guys, how are you? Happy birthday!
- Good to see ya.
- Thank you.
- Tell me Brody, was that a surprise?
- Were you surprised?
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- Tell me, how was the party?
- It was really good.
My mom and brother were in on it.
My brother said, "What are
all those people there for?"
- There was a big group
there and he's like,
"What are all these people here for?"
- I thought they were there
for the ice cream truck.
But when I realized that
they were all there for me
and there were cameras pointed to me.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- [Brody] I just started to tear up.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Brody] I hugged my mom.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- [Brody] She had to pull
me away from the party.
- Yeah, he was a little overwhelmed.
- Well, as you go through life,
you'll find more and
more people on your side,
that's what life is.
There always more people
on your side than not.
And there's always gonna be
those people and you know,
all the people on your side
make you a stronger person.
I'm glad you had an amazing birthday.
God bless you, man and both of you.
What a great mom.
Thanks, happy birthday, Brody.
Everybody, happy birthday, Brody.
(audience cheering)
- Happy birthday, Brody!
- [Man] We're liking your post right now.
(audience cheering)
Hey, that's not all,
Kelly's long season partner,
Pilot Pen, the go-to pen
in the Kelly Clarkson Show
wants to honor ultimate
overachievers just like you guys.
There'll be using their G2 gel
ink pen to write you a check
for $1,000.
So there you go, all right.
(audience cheering)
All right, smile on that.
Now before you go, I remind
you, I gotta new game show.
It's a revival of the type of
game show you bet your life.
Check on local listings,
find out when it's on.
Thanks everybody, thanks for having me on.